I LOVE THE SHOW
MORGAN FREEMAN HAS ON
THE SCIENCE CHANNEL, "THROUGH
THE WORMHOLE."
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
AND WEDNESDAY NIGHT AT 8:00,
HE'S TAKING ON THE SUBJECT OF
BIGOTRY SO LUCKILY FOR YOU HE
JUMPED THROUGH THE TIME WORMHOLE
AND TOLD SOUL DADDY ALL ABOUT
IT.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
TAKE A LOOK.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, WE'VE GOT
THE FIFTH DIMENSION COMING OUT
LATER.
IT'S GOING TO BE A STONE COLD
PICNIC.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
SPEAKING OF DIMENSIONS.
WE'VE GOT THIS CAT OVER HERE HE
CLAIMS HE'S FROM THE FUTURE.
HIS NAME IS MORGAN FREEMAN.
I KNOW HIM FROM THE ELECTRIC
COMPANY BUT HE SAYS HE WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT WORMHOLES.
BROTHER, LET'S DO THIS.
WHAT IS THE WORMHOLE?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ANYWAY?
>> IT'S AN IMAGINARY PLACE IN
SPACE WHERE IF YOU GET TO IT,
YOU CAN MOVE ALMOST ANYWHERE IN
THE UNIVERSE.
>> Larry: THAT SOUNDS LIKE
WHITE FLIGHT.
( LAUGHTER )
WHAT WOULD BE THE DRUG OF CHOICE
FOR SOMEONE TO TAKE IN THE
WORMHOLE?
>> I SAY ACID.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> I'D SAY MARIJUANA.
IT'S LEGAL NOW IN PLACES.
>> Larry: GET THE ( BLEEP )
OUT OF HERE.
SO THIS WORMHOLE SHOW, THIS
SOUNDS LIKE IT WOULD BE A
VARIETY SHOW BECAUSE VARIETY
SHOWS ARE NOT GOING AWAY, BY THE
WAY.
WHO YOU HAVE GLENN CAMPBELL?
>> NO.
>> Larry: CHARLES?
CHARLES IS A TALENT.
>> PHYSICISTS AND SCIENTISTS AND
PEOPLE LIKE THAT ON OUR VARIETY
SHOW.
I'D HAVE TROUBLE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS.
>> Larry: YOU HAVE SEEN HER
PLAY THE GUITAR?
( LAUGHTER )
THERE'S A SHOW SATURDAY MORNING
CALLED "SHAZAM."
IT'S A KID'S SHOW.
THEY GOT THIS CHARACTER NAMED
ISIS.
SHE'S LIKE A GODDESS.
I WOULD HATE FOR SOMEBODY TO
RUIN A NAME LIKE THAT.
WE ALL HAVE BIG BUTTS.
THAT'S TRUE.
>> I DON'T.
>> Larry: WHAT HAPPENED TO
YOUR BUTT?
>> IN THE YEAR 2015, HAVE WE
HAD, LIKE, A NEGRO
SECRETARY OF STATE?
>> AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE'VE
HAD A NEGRO WOMAN.
>> Larry: YEAH, WE HAD A SOUL
SISTER AS SECRETARY.
>> I'M ABOUT TO OFFER YOU A
SHOCK.
>> Larry: WHAT'S THAT?
>> BLACK PRESIDENT.
>> Larry: OH, COME ON, MAN.
>> A TRUE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
>> Larry: HE'S PROBABLY HALF
BLACK.
>> YEAH, HE IS.
>> SEE? THERE YOU GO
WHAT RACE IS BIGFOOT UNDER ALL
THAT FUR DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S HARD
TO SAY.
THEY SAY THAT MOST SKIN UNDER
THE FUR IS PINK.
>> Larry: SO WHAT DOES THAT
MAKE HIM?
>> WHITE.
>> Larry: BIGFOOT IS WHITE?
>> YEAH
>> THAT'S WHY HE'S NEVER BEEN
SHOT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US ON "SOUL
DADDY."
BEST OF LUCK IN YOUR CAREER.
YOU SEEM LIKE A CHARMING YOUNG
FELLA.
NEVER GO INTO VOICEOVER, TRUST
ME
>>I KNOW WISDOM WHEN I HEAR IT
>> TUNE IN EVERY OTHER WEDNESDAY
FOR ANOTHER EPISODE OF
SOUL DADDY." SOMEBODY LIGHT
THIS, PLEASE.
( APPLAUSE )
DON'T WORRY, WE'LL SEND AN
INTERN INTO THAT WORMHOLE TO
PULL MORGAN FREEMAN OUT.